at one point Chris's character insults
Yours by calling you a Ken doll which is
not an insult
at all I'm proud of that you you now are
playing Ken yeah well I have that
kennergy you sure do he could feel
obviously when you commented on it and
you know it's uh I still feel like the
kennergy is alive and can you explain
the kenergy for me
I can't you'll you I mean did you know
what I mean no well your lovely wife I
know it can in your life and then you
know that that Ken has Kennedy that's
Kennedy well it's the kennesaws per yeah
do you love that she coined that term
for you I loved it I thought it was um
I love that she's got love for Ken that
means a lot to me you know Margot Robbie
told us whatever we think the Barbie
movie is it's not that right how would
you tease the movie or respond to that
quote I think I would never
correct Barbie
sure I would never dream of it I would
say whatever Barbie says is exactly
right she's right if it's not what you
think it is
unless it is
and then you know what it is and then it
but but I don't think that's what you
think it is what is it wait what are we
talking about the Barbie movie oh yeah
I'm excited are you yes I mean people
are going nuts for the photos of it I
can't I can't wait that's nothing that's
nothing I can't wait for people to see
the phones
give me one not what you expect it's not
what you said one word that's that's
that's all I could say okay
otherwise Mattel will come in and box me
up
well that's kind of the point or is it I
don't know
um
it's real than maybe were you more buff
for The Gray Man or Barbie because we
see Ken's ABS right right
yeah that Ken life is
that Kent life is it's that's it's even
harder than the gray man life I think
really yeah
in what ways
he's got
Ken's got no money he's got no job
he's got no car
he's got no house
wow you know
okay he's going through some stuff wow
maybe the canisance isn't what we
thought it was
maybe it's time
has Ava seen any of the movie what does
she think of him
well I can't I can't comment for her
but she has seen some of the film yeah
and have something they really want but
it's your gut it's going to be my
funeral you're going to next you want to
make an omelet you gotta kill some
people
the movie's so good I don't know how to
say it I didn't breathe for two hours
because of the action but it breathed
when I laughed which was often so it's
just so great so thank you for making a
great fun movie to watch oh cool thank
you it was fun
um you and Chris you're great together
you know we were thinking I'm like you
have had some amazing chemistry with
your leading co-stars over the years
Emma Stone Miss Ava Mendes
how is the chemistry with you and Chris
Evans how does it compare
it doesn't compare to the mine with uh
with Ava at all it doesn't chart but he
uh you know Chris ran mustache first
into this role he had a lot of fun
playing it sure did and it made it fun
to play against you know did you think
about growing a mustache after seeing
his
oh no no okay is that in
here
[Music]
I mean you too the the combat sequences
are just captivating what was the
training like for this role to get in
shape for that to do those scenes
it's all the boring stuff that you know
like you lift heavy things you don't eat
a lot of other things you know but what
I didn't realize was just how many
people it takes to make an action hero
you know like it looks like it's me you
know doing all those things and yes I do
you know some of it but in you know
incredible stun team credible special
effects team
but you're at your arm at one point we
see a shot of your arm and it's it looks
huge right where did you bulk up more
for this role than any other part before
yeah it's just it was a very physical
yeah you know role so there was a lot of
a lot of that stuff and uh you know it
was just a physical challenge in in
every way we hadn't seen you on screen
in a couple years what made you want to
come back with this movie and bring this
action movie to everybody and what did
you love about it
you know I've always wanted to make an
action film I they're what made me fall
in love with movies you know I just uh
took me a long time to find the right
one you know
um this and when I read this I just
thought this you know this this is it
you know it's it's like the films I grew
up loving you know it has like the 80s
and 90s action films it's
it's fun like the character has a sense
of humor about the situations that he's
in like it's it's an Escapist uh movie
it sort of had this that that tone that
I
that that I that I loved and and I
really liked the character you know I
thought it was
it was like
you know it was like a spy who doesn't
want to be a spy who'd rather be at home
watching Netflix like the rest of us you
know he doesn't want to have anything to
do with this
he has to and so it made it interesting
like made him an interesting character
but
foreign
[Music]